welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
today we have stevo beloved by
all one of the most cherished and
wonderful people on this planet and we
have a fantastic conversation with him
before we get into that i quickly want
to thank our sponsor expressvpn
and let you guys know that there is a
new september release at teddyfresh.com
let me briefly show you what we've got
out
new color block hoodies ba boom we've
got this one
here let me zoom in a little bit for you
not very high res
photo but you get the idea this one's
beautiful beautiful beautiful
new color blocks new felt hats
i love this hat i lost mine i need elo
to bring me new ones
but i mean it's such a nice hat new ela
client original
her marker drawing this is what i'm
wearing now it's awesome
shorts uh grandpa jacket this is
everyone's favorite piece
mike my grandpa died and all he left me
was this jacket
passed away and left me all this jacket
excuse me
anyway really nice jacket god bless
and then we've got some striped shirts
and all kinds of
colors this is my brainchild of course
which is a skeleton burning violently
and then the lyrics to friends
on the bottom so no one told you life
was going to be this way
it's a i mean come on who wouldn't want
that
uh that's my favorite piece
i mean i made it so maybe a little bit
of a bias
teddy fresh crayon shirts puffy paint
you know yada yada just head on over to
teddyfresh.com peep out the new
collection and
hopefully pick something up if you like
it alright that being said
let's jump right in to stevo
today your host the fresh prince of dead
air
brings you one of our most maybe
most cherished guests of all time
stevo a man who needs no introduction at
all
is with us here via the power of zoom
and i do want to tell you stevo before
we get
into any conversation at all ian can you
please pull up stevo's wiki
page
so it's customary here on the issue
podcast to rate
our guests wiki feet are you aware of
what keeps oh
wow dude i've heard about this it's a uh
like a foot fetish thing huh yeah and
actually
i have to give it up to you my dude you
have a pretty solid rating
nice 4.53 so that's definitely something
to be proud of there
that's crazy because on my podcast which
is of course called
wild ride with stevo i'm always
barefoot and i always get
[ __ ] comments about dude wash your
feet your [ __ ]
feet are disgusting okay so that's
that's
like it's my disgusting
unclean feet which uh
are responsible for my high rating huh
oh that wonders
straight on wiki
yeah wow i think you just lost some
points
oh yeah i don't know dude maybe my other
maybe maybe the other foot will bring it
up
yeah i don't know man like so stevo i
watched your new comedy special
gnarly brad thank you man
it was horrific and beautiful all at
once
it's on stevo.com for 10 bucks
apparently no streaming service would
pick it up because it was just so
obscene is that right
basically yeah it uh it's got a lot of
dicks
well it has just my dick it's got a lot
of my dick it's got uh
you know a lot of um heavy drugs
um a lot of uh criminal activity
grievous grievous bodily harm
i really go get [ __ ] up um
so between those things um
it was tough to get it anywhere and then
frankly
with the uh you know the platforms that
you know i think could have put it out
like netflix uh
you know probably hbo and showtime i
think that would be about
it and their position i think
was that uh viewing stevo as a
crossover stand-up comedian you know not
a pure
lifelong stand-up comedian that i'm not
prestigious enough
to give a stand-up comedy special too
and that absolutely drove me nuts man
that [ __ ] that drove me nuts because
what i did with it
like i i don't think it's ever been done
before to have
uh fully multimedia stand-up comedy
with uh you know because most comedians
i think their stories that they're
telling aren't
true to begin with and in my case not
only are they true but i've got the
footage
to like really illustrate the stories
and uh [ __ ] man i just thought that
between having the multimedia component
and bringing the whole cast of jackass
together to do such
awesome [ __ ] for it that it was a
no-brainer a slam dunk
and i'd and like you said i couldn't
[ __ ] sell it man
so was there anybody did it was anyone
interested in they're like okay we can
do this but you have to remove all the
dicks
and the gore and all this [ __ ] or is it
all i never
um i never would have edited anything
out but it didn't come to that
yeah it so it didn't come to that and i
i mean honestly i felt like uh
dr dre when uh i was watching his uh
defiant ones series on hbo
he said that they had the chronic you
know
the chronic and he brought it to all the
record labels and they all passed
on it and uh and he's like i knew it was
[ __ ] great
i think that's maybe why he started
aftermath records you know
and i was like just so [ __ ] pissed
that i i couldn't sell it i thought it
was just like
such a slam dunk millions of dollars and
um
i ended up putting it out on my own
website which in hindsight
might have been [ __ ] awesome too
it might have been completely rad
because
and i'll tell you the business of it you
know i spent just to shoot the [ __ ]
thing
like a quarter million dollars easy just
the night in the theater
i forget what was it uh 120 170 or
something but
i shot so many different things like to
to build into it like that opening
sequence which i'm so stoked that
when i was with you we recorded the
podcast last time i told you i was like
man they're gonna duct tape me to a side
of a truck and i'm gonna drive to vegas
and we ended up doing it in denver so
the opening sequence you see me riding
duct tape to the side of this truck
all the way to denver and uh that plus
all the other
you know special scenes we shot for it
it was a [ __ ] quarter million bucks
by the time i filmed it easy
i figured it would cost more than that
yeah yeah
right oh well then getting it out on my
website took it
like over 300 000 oh wow
yeah because there was a lot in in uh
you know
in uh like promotion hiring the
publicist
with mixing you know and then i bought
the [ __ ]
billboard to promote it you know
right right with the hollywood sign in
the background
and then i [ __ ] hired two two uh
cranes i had a [ __ ] construction team
with two
cranes and and got me all up on the
[ __ ] billboard
uh so yeah it was a lot but uh
thankfully i made my money back
yeah and some good
like uh i checked it last night
and um and uh with like
having spent 300 grand like i've brought
in
523 000 so
that's i'm in the profit zone thank god
for that well now it's all
it's all just money and i think i think
people
if they go over to siva.com and watch
gnarly they're going to be very
satisfied with their ten dollars
this man died nearly died for this [ __ ]
yeah i appreciate that man i appreciate
that a lot and uh
my philosophy is that um you know i
that i really think anybody who does
stream it from stevo.com is going to be
thoroughly happy with
it because this project marries all of
my worlds together into one
you know and it's like not only am i not
uh
[ __ ] any wiser or you know like i'm
doing dumber [ __ ] than ever
yeah you know what i was like man i was
just wondering like when is he gonna get
too old for this [ __ ] because your body
cannot be getting stronger or more
durable as you
age and the [ __ ] that you're doing in
this is is crazier
than anything you've done right at what
point are you just gonna have to call it
a day on this stuff
dude i've got the next uh
i mean depending on when um you know the
world opens back
up so to speak i mean i've got the net
i've got the next project
[ __ ] done you know like um the the
the follow-up to gnarly
is is [ __ ] finished man um and i've
been touring with it
because i'm yeah i'm so [ __ ]
pissed about this dude i taped the
gnarly special
in january of 2018.
so i it didn't come out until i'd been
[ __ ] sitting
on it for two and a half years and
and and when i failed to
get anybody to [ __ ] buy it it which
drives me [ __ ] crazy
just to say that but um like
i didn't get discouraged and say like
okay
i'm gonna [ __ ] you know just hang it
up whatever
nobody was interested [ __ ] that i
doubled down dude
i doubled down and i knew exactly what
the follow-up to gnarly was going to be
because uh i was because i the thing
about gnarly
there's all this storytelling and then
each bit in the act
inspires like a crazy new stunt and i
was just excited about
making the follow-up like no more
[ __ ] memory lane [ __ ] like 100
brand new like over the just over the
top stuff
and then the question of what to do next
like i already had the answer because
like for all these last 20 years
since jackass started there's been like
a handful of ideas
that i had and just never
[ __ ] thought i was gonna do them you
know like they were just like the go-to
like i was skydiving like only if i'm
butt naked
with the tandem instructor strapped to
my back
and i'm furiously jacking off and i time
it so i fall out of the airplane while
i'm coming everywhere
disgusting yeah it's called skyjacking
that's the closer for the bucket the
bucket that's what this new
this new one is called the bucket list
and like
i had you know for decades i had the
idea to get a vasectomy
and right after i get the vasectomy go
like
get on a horse bare back horseback
riding bouncing up and down on my balls
and like and and
like dressed up as a pinata with all the
kids hitting me in the balls with
with a stick there the vasectomy
olympics so did you do that
oh yeah
you got engaged at the end of the
special congratulations i mean it's
really beautiful
seems like a really beautiful wholesome
relationship i knew she was special
when she encouraged you to eat your
burned dead
skin so that was a really uh touching
moment in the
in gnarly yeah dude thank you man yeah
she's definitely the one
and uh there was another moment if i
could interject
when she injected the hot sauce into
your uh [ __ ]
i thought that was a really beautiful uh
i realized you guys were kindred spirits
then as well
yeah for sure man i appreciate that a
lot
yeah she never wanted kids i don't want
kids
um you know it's uh
yeah [ __ ] it dude we're all about
animals yeah dogs are great
yeah we have four dogs we have uh
two cats we've got three goats
like all right here at our house i
wanted to ask you about
uh your animal rights advocacy because
it's always been something that stood
out to me is interesting
you've lived such a crazy life
um what is it about animals i mean of
all the causes you could take up in the
world why is it that you're so
passionate about
animal animal rights um
you know it uh i i think i can
i can distill this down to a pretty
bite-sized
uh timeline when i was at
ringling brothers and barnum and bailey
clown college
you know i think it's pretty well known
that my career began
as a circus clown and when i was in
clown college
the public relations department for the
ringling brothers and barnum and billy
circus paid us a visit and they said
some of you
are going to be working for the the
greatest show on earth the ringling
brothers barnum billy circus and what
that's going to entail
is is arriving in the city like a week
in advance of the circus
to do uh interviews to promote
you know and when you're doing these
interviews
some people are going to ask you about
animal abuse you know like with the
with the elephants all the tigers
everything in the circus and if you
if and when you get asked about animal
abuse you shut the [ __ ] up you have no
opinion
you're a [ __ ] clown you fall down you
don't say anything you know like that's
how i remember them kind of coming at us
and i thought well [ __ ]
the way that they're approaching this
with us
seems like it's really [ __ ] shady you
know so if i if i could point to a
moment
where animal abuse and animal rights
like first occurred to me because i
never never even thought of it before
that and i thought man maybe the circus
is [ __ ] up
then i went on to work in the circus and
not not the ringling circus but i worked
in another circus that had
three elephants and a tiger and dude
the [ __ ] circus owners were more
terrified of their own elephants
than anybody in the audience the tiger
went from its whole life
from one box to another box back and
forth and
both boxes were like the [ __ ] length
of the tiger's body
i was i was kind of [ __ ] upset about
it you know like the elephant
and i was like [ __ ] this then uh you
know
my last day working in the circus was my
first day of filming
jackass it was just that like i washed
off my clown makeup
knives with knoxville like they [ __ ]
filmed my last performance and then i
was off
you know with jackass after that once i
had a platform
and uh you know i'm doing like
talking to big audiences i would [ __ ]
about the animals in the circus i was
like
[ __ ] that dude i was in the circus and
[ __ ] that man those animals are abused
and so then you know when i went on one
of my rants
about the animal abuse and the circus
then
the people from peta reached out to me
and said hey could we get you to say
that
for for peta and i was like [ __ ] yeah
i'm an attention [ __ ] you got a camera
i'm in
and uh and so i did that and then
i've never supported peta on like
you know across the board because
they've got some wacky views man i don't
back
everything that they're about but what i
did was just gradually kind of bit by
bit
on an issue by issue basis i became more
in
you know i was like i was like you know
i don't
[ __ ] uh yeah i won't wear fur
because i don't eat mink was my first
thing they said oh cool we'll do an
anti-fur campaign
and i graduate and then when i was so
out of control on drugs and
hallucinating everywhere
with all that and that was one of the
most popular things from our last
podcast was
the ghost stories where i was talking
about all the [ __ ] crazy experience i
had with
spirit [ __ ] ghost [ __ ] and and when i
was
when i was like watching people walk
around and walk through walls and all
this [ __ ] i was like
so in love with the experience of it
and i was so interested to learn about
like what
the [ __ ] was going on with the spirit
world and so there i am with all my
drugs
piles of [ __ ] coke and
nitrous all this crazy [ __ ] and uh i'm
researching spirit world like watching
youtube videos
and i saw this [ __ ] like harry
krishna guy from
india or something and he's this wise
guru man and he says
how can you expect to be saved if you
eat meat you know and he was just like
you know and i was like right there i
was like boom [ __ ] i want to be saved
you know so that was where i i stopped
eating meat except for fish
and i just it just came more and more
you know the more
when i got sober like if i could make
decisions based on
kind of just being compassionate then
that
helped build up my self-esteem you know
like i had i had it pretty low
where i was you know just kind of you
know
my life was not good and i built myself
back up by
making decisions that i could be proud
of and and a lot of that was uh just
turning my attention to animals
why is it that fish always get the the
exception
i always wondered that i would me too
man that was
when i first decided but i'm gonna keep
eating fish
it was because i said uh well eating
fish has to be cool because [ __ ]
jesus
was a fisherman you know i i no longer
believe that jesus had [ __ ]
anything to do with fish or fishermen
or or fishing uh but
i gotta say that i went back to eating
fish i was vegan for
uh [ __ ] i was vegan for years
and then i went back to eating fish
uh for a couple reasons number one um
i think it's good for me number two i've
got all these animals that i can't
feed a vegan diet you know and so
giving fish to my that's all my you know
the dog food everything the cat food i
like i i
limit it at fish and and i'm like what
am i gonna feed the [ __ ] fish to my
pets and not eat it myself i think it's
good for me it is good for you yeah
i just i find that a lot of vegetarians
just they
there's this one like uh kurt cobain
line he says it's okay to eat fish
because they don't have any feelings you
know
that's not true they did
yeah they told they totally have
feelings they totally have feelings they
totally have
their families they have [ __ ] like
you know emotions i believe all that
but that what helps me a little bit
is that you know the most horrifying of
all
is factory farming right you know like
it's just factory farming with the eggs
and
you know the all the the chicken just
the
the conditions that they have animals
living in farms is awful
yeah and and and with wild caught fish
in my view that fish had a great life
just roaming around swimming in the
ocean
you know and then it got [ __ ] caught
and and then you know
it had its death everything dies but you
know i think death is
pretty easy in the grand scheme of
things it's going to happen anyway
it's it's how you live that's important
and i like to think
even if it's naive that the fish that i
eat
had a good life swimming around you know
yeah i think that's a fair
observation is a guy like you afraid of
death i wonder because you
you squirt by it yeah
are you really though are you really
like totally unafraid of death
i mean i'm afraid of suffering yeah and
i think that that's the i think the
actual
being dead has to be okay
otherwise we're really [ __ ] you know
yeah um like
like i can't i can't subscribe to an
idea that being dead
is a bad thing you know being dead is
not death itself i'm not worried about
you know it's like the idea of prolonged
pain and suffering
yeah and um and even more than that
i think what's terrifying is uh
i'm not going to be here anymore you
know like you asked
a big question you know and
mortality is
it's not necessarily oh i'm going to be
dead but like i'm not going to be here
anymore
you know like we have uh as as humans
we have only one instinct which is to
survive
right and we have only one guarantee
we won't survive so like wait a second
hold like hold on here
the one [ __ ] thing that matters to us
above all else the one [ __ ] thing
we're trying to avoid
is the only thing that we can be sure of
so this is like some kind of a [ __ ]
catch-22
like prank on us what the [ __ ] is this
human experience but
a [ __ ] awful joke where the one thing
we're passionate about is the only
[ __ ]
it's it's [ __ ] the innovation yeah
right so i i view that as
really the big picture of the human
experience
is to one way or another wrap your head
around
your mortality you know to come to terms
with okay like i'm gonna die
and how's that okay and i think that
there are three ways
that people typically have done it
throughout history
number one being to reproduce you know
there's this idea that yeah i'll be gone
but my legacy will live on i'm gonna
have children who
you know keep me alive you know and like
we've covered that i don't [ __ ]
want to reproduce you know so that
doesn't work for me
i think the other way the other way
people wrap their head around
death is uh religion you know where they
subscribe to some like sort of fairy
tale notion
that uh you know if they do x y or z
that they're going to be in heaven
and everything's so that's oh you know
i'm going to be dead but i'll be in
heaven
and like the idea of a heaven which is
exclusive to people who
subscribe to one absurd belief is
[ __ ]
just pisses me off man you know i grew
up with people of all
faiths and like if they're not all
welcome in heaven then [ __ ] it i don't
want to go
you know they just religion i've always
had a little bit of a chip on my
shoulder so that's not my gig
and then the third way the that we sort
of come to terms with death
you know i like like the [ __ ] caveman
scrawling the [ __ ]
stick figures on the cave wall because
they know they're gonna be dead
but their [ __ ] stick figures will
outlive them you know
now that's me 100 that's me that's where
i turned to the video camera
you know as a failing college student i
was like dude
i'm gonna fail at life because i can't
keep a job and i can't
[ __ ] go to class i can't survive
but before i [ __ ] die man i'm gonna
load up my message into the bottle
i'm gonna [ __ ] videotape crazy [ __ ]
and those videos are gonna live on
so when i'm dead like it'll be cool
because i'll still be alive
with the [ __ ] immortality of the
video
can i ask yeah
this is kind of like a broad question
but you ever think about like
how you ended up the way you are you
know what i mean i know exactly
at a young age you were like already
living way too fast and too hard you
know
what the clown college and the drug use
and just like you just said yourself you
didn't plan
i don't think to live very long i didn't
i didn't expect to see the age of 30.
i never you know and from the from when
i was eight
i don't think i was i'd ever like i
had the idea i was gonna be dead yeah
yeah did you have
drama sort of
here's this is real simple because like
the the my mom's side of the family
is a hundred percent alcoholic
a highlight like it's alcohol drugs
gambling suicide like this is just
the whole every leaf on the tree you
know
like uh my mom her brother and her
sister there were three siblings
all dead from alcoholism 100 you know
cirrhosis like you know like you know
like whatever all the way up as far as
anybody can remember
every single person died of alcoholism
suicide like
you know whatever um so there's this
kind of deviance of course with that
said my mom was the
the smart one my mom was the funny one
my mom was
the one with the personality then my my
dad's side of the family
was a hundred percent uh theologians
[ __ ] clergy men you know like
decorated academics like
super decorated academics and my dad was
uh sort of the black sheep of the family
for going into business
you know they were like nobody ever on
my dad's side of the family made a lot
of money but they were just respected
[ __ ] good ass people and my dad was
this hustler
you know he [ __ ] top of his class he
went on to become uh
the president of pepsi cola in all of
brazil the president of nabisco like i
grew up in a privileged ass upbringing
and and uh and it's like
i'm a hybrid of these two family trees
you know it's like i've got my dad's
my dad's drive my dad's [ __ ]
hustle and that's the engine for
my mom's deviance you know i'm just this
[ __ ] alcoholic deviant just with
hustle so did your mom kind of what was
it like growing up with your mom
did she was there moments where
you kind of saw either that dark side of
her or like she kind of
oh yeah did she abuse you no no no there
wasn't any abuse
but um i was born in england
and my family moved to brazil when i was
just
six months old so um that was because
dad got the job of
president of pepsi cola in all of brazil
and they were ballin dude they were the
[ __ ] was popping off
man like when you're living in brazil
and you have like this
kind of status like it's i mean the cost
of living
was cheap as [ __ ] so if you're making if
you're making any kind of real money
living in brazil you're bawling and they
were like ball and balling
so they had live-in maids which uh
you know essentially raised me you know
like i i actually spoke my first words
in portuguese because
the only people [ __ ] paying attention
to me were the live-in maids
who spoke portuguese so it's not like
hard to imagine you know how i became
such a [ __ ] attention [ __ ] because
mom and dad weren't paying any attention
to me and that's not because they were
abusive or you know
they were just balling and [ __ ]
partying
and like didn't have time so i think
that there's
a big component in that that makes me
like
really over developed my need for
attention
and uh and as such i'm uh i like to
consider myself a world-class attention
[ __ ]
yes for sure you've achieved a lot
through that the
singular yeah but so you know i
stumbled onto a really great character
defect yeah exactly you've worked it to
your advantage for sure
so your debt was your mom working when
you guys were in brazil
she wasn't she went to nursing school
and i want to say that she dropped out
of nursing school
um when she married my dad
and to my mom's credit my dad when they
married
had not uh had like huge success
you know my wife was not jumping on the
bandwagon
of uh my mom she like dad hadn't done
[ __ ] yet
and and and he did it he succeeded after
marrying my mom
which i think is really cool yeah that
is nice
your dad was in your special or do you
hold
any grudges or resentments to your
parents still as a
as you no no no no no no no not at all
not at all and with my dad
uh it's it's so rad to me
that that my dad uh didn't jump on any
bandwagons with with me
you know just kind of figuring things
out like um
i i had this crazy dad wasn't supportive
of me dropping out of college he was
not [ __ ] feeling clown college
he he [ __ ] hated every word i had to
say about i'm gonna become a crazy
famous stuntman he [ __ ] hated all of
it
and uh and and and to his credit it was
before
i um before i
had ever even made a [ __ ] penny
being a dumbass [ __ ] stuntman that my
dad
came to me and he said hey i gotta tell
you i feel i've done a disservice to you
by not supporting you in this career
path that you're clearly committed to
you know and uh and he said i feel like
i've done a disservice and i want you to
know that sure you didn't choose what i
would have wanted you to do
but i see that you're committed i just
want you to be the best and i've got
your back
you know he gave and i think a lot of
fathers have had that
talk with their kids you know he said
okay my uh my dad
said that how his his dad
totally didn't support him going into
business you know i said it was the
black sheep
a capitalist greedy scumbag in a
business suit
my dad was like yeah he's like and his
his dad had the same talk with him
i'm going to throw to a quick break and
then when we come back we will continue
this conversation
with stevo when you use the bathroom
you always close the door behind you
right you don't want random passer
buyers looking in on you
so why would you let people look in on
you when you go online
using the internet without expressvpn is
like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door
or in some stalls they leave that little
crack that gives me a ton of anxiety
you ever meet eyes through the crack
you i always do like this you know when
i'm taking a dump and there's that giant
crack
that somebody walks by and you catch
their eye
that's [ __ ] up and expressvpn closes
that crack
for you did you know that your internet
service provider like comcast or verizon
knows every single website you visit
ian did you know that ian
yeah be careful and what's worse is they
can
sell this info to ad companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you
expressvp expressvpn
puts a stop to this it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
your online activity can't be seen by
anyone i use expressvpn on all my
devices
and it works on everything phones
laptops even
routers so everyone who shares your
wi-fi can still be protected even if
they don't have
expressvpn and the best part is using
expressvpn is as easy as closing a
bathroom door
you just fire up the app you click one
button and
boom you're protected expressvpn is the
world's number one rated vpn
by cnet wired the verge and countless
others
so if you're like me and you believe
your online activity is your business
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
h3 today use my exclusive link
e x p r e s s vpn
dot com slash h3 and you can get an
extra three months
for free that's expressvpn.com
h3
welcome back real quick zach you had a
question for stevo
yeah you know i i loved your new special
stevo and like i grew up a jackass fan
um when you put that condom full of
weed in you how did you not die from
that like that was insane
okay yeah i mean well again thank you
so much for watching it dude i really i
love everything about that damn gnarly
special
and uh you know the idea
for the drug smuggling bit where in the
special i get arrested
for international drug smuggling it came
from staying at this chick's house there
was a period when i first moved out to
la
where chris pontius and i were both
completely homeless and we had this
running competition
to see who could stay homeless
the longest despite the fact that now we
were earning enough money to be able to
rent an apartment
you know it was like it was this funny
game that we were playing
and at a certain point we were both
staying at this girl's house
she was out of town we were uh
house-sitting taking care of her dog
which was this little
10 pound like [ __ ] terrier
whatever and so chris and i come back
from the bar
with these two chicks we're in this
girl's place
and we both in separate rooms are
humping
these these danish chicks right they're
both from denmark
and uh as per usual i had this little
habit where i took off my
soiled condom and like would tie it in a
knot
and like you know that would like swirl
it around be like
yeah you know and would throw it right
like so i did that
in in this girl's house threw my tied
under knot rubber
through it and then i'm or whatever at
the time i've smoked cigarettes i'm
smoking a cigarette and i remember
seeing the little 10 pound dog
coming running into the room and it
runs out of the room and i'm like okay
you know that's uh
but then after i get done with my
cigarette i get up and i look on the
ground like where's the condom
like it's not here and i'm thinking oh
no
so in my view this is the worst because
the girl whose house we were staying at
had a boyfriend you know and like
if this dog picked up the condom and
took it on like a little victory lap and
dropped it somewhere else
where the [ __ ] boyfriend's gonna find
it in her place
like that's gonna be a problem so i'm
all kinds of [ __ ] stressed out about
it and like
and then and i can't find it anywhere
and then even worse what if the dog
swallowed the [ __ ] thing
and it gets tangled up in the dog's
intestines or something and like string
you know the dog dies because it [ __ ]
gobbled my rubber
so i was like the rest of the time at
this girl's house i'm
like walking the dog i'm like you know
like checking every you know when the
dog poops
i think i forget how long it was it
wasn't too long
but i woke up from a crazy drug bender
at like
[ __ ] six and six pm or something
and right next to the bed i was sleeping
in is this
piece of [ __ ] dog poop which just
morphed into my rubber you know
it was like it was like half log and
hammered
yeah and and like and i grabbed my
camera
and [ __ ] uh i grabbed my camera and
and
lifted it up by the ring of the rubber
and it the the rubber gets like all
straightened out
and once it really once it's fully
straight
the the piece of dog poo is just
sticking out perpendicular in the middle
you know and you can see the whole load
of [ __ ]
was was intact in the you know after
passing through the whole dog
that whole the whole load was just
perfectly intact in the rubber
and uh you know i put it out on my first
uh my first dvd
which i actually just uploaded into this
video library at stevo.com when you see
the first
stevo don't try this at home video and
career ender
that's on there but uh but yeah so i
felt like [ __ ] okay thank god
we figured that out i got a cool piece
of footage out of it
but i felt [ __ ] bad when mike comes
coming out of that dog's [ __ ]
it's not it's not a lot different than
the dog being sodomized by me
you know just the comes going in the
other direction
you know and uh and i felt that i owed
it to that dog somehow and so i was like
okay you know if the dog can
swallow a condom and have it come out
all intact then i should be able to
as well so that was the birth of the
idea how am i gonna what am i gonna do
swallowing a condom and then when i went
on the europe tour i said dude i'm going
to load up a condom with [ __ ]
weed in one country and then fly to the
next country and [ __ ] it out and smoke
it
and so that was the where the idea but
it turned into this crazy debacle
because
like zach said it would [ __ ] thing
wouldn't come out
and i thought i was going to die because
it was going to block up
all of my [ __ ] you know you stuck a lot
i think you put you put a lot of weed in
there
a lot i know and i
yeah i didn't even think i did it was
stuck in my throat
you know like it was the most it was the
most [ __ ] scary thing
and then everyone was telling me that
like you can get blockage in your
intestines
and like you know and and like and i saw
i was really
worried that i was gonna die of
intestinal strangulation
and uh i [ __ ] i expressed these
concerns
to every media outlet that i talked to
that was just like
and and they're not [ __ ] cool about
drugs in sweden they really aren't
so so yeah it came out in the newspaper
that i had drugs in my body
before the drugs were out of my body
and uh the cops [ __ ] swooped in
to [ __ ] nail me for international
drug smuggling
the whole story is crazy and it's in the
gnarly special so
by all means please go over to uh
stevo.com
and uh and stream that [ __ ]
there's the
that's like the most square [ __ ] i ever
heard like apparently
there's so little going on in sweden the
cops arrested you
and then made you [ __ ] in a cup for a
week to
check for the weed yeah it wasn't a cup
it was a bag it was it was it was a
[ __ ] uh
a little yeah it was a toilet that had
like a bag set up in the bowl
oh that's so so this isn't the first
time they've dealt with this issue
[Laughter]
right i get it so the most discussed i
mean
the part that stands out to me from
gnarly
is the jet fuel accident yeah
you laid in jet fuel and got third
degree burns all over your body
and you didn't go to the hospital for
like a week too so everything was all
infected and [ __ ] and then of course as
i mentioned
earlier your your our fiance or not wife
is it
uh still haven't gotten married we're
we're waiting to
buy a big farm that we're gonna get
married on oh
perfect fiance uh was encouraging you to
because your skin
was just coming off and peels and
and then you started eating it how was
that experience i mean you tossed it
down real fast but that technically
makes you a cannibal doesn't it
it does man i got what it was was that
that you know the skin was just
the skin was just falling off my body
wholesale
and as each patch came off i i threw him
into the toilet i threw it all and then
it just occurred to me like looking in
the toilet and all this skin
floating in there i was just like that
is the sight to behold
you know that's something that's
something that's pretty [ __ ]
remarkable
right i was like okay so i got my girl
to film
and i scooped it out of the toilet and
then we had this whole conversation
about i was like i should not eat that
and she's like quiet i'm like you're
you're your silence is speaking volumes
you know like you want me to eat this
and she's like
so does she not gag during that does she
have a really strong stomach to be able
to watch you do that
it's so interesting how like
like the the workings of my girl's mind
like the things that she's
perfectly comfortable with like are
just outrageous you know like she didn't
gag she was like totally
supportive of like yeah [ __ ] eat your
skin that's great you know
you know like uh she filmed me drinking
the blister juice and
and had no problem oh yeah i wanted to
ask you about that we'll work up into
that
and and for anybody that's concerned
that this might
all be too gross keep in mind that's i
saved that for the end
you know me getting third degree burns
all over my body and
skin graft surgery and all of this stuff
we're describing right now
is the closer for the gnarly specialist
after you
after you eat your own flesh
and by the way so you're like there's a
moment where their flesh is kind of
peeling off
and you're jiggling it and you can see
there's like actually just liquid in
there
like what kind of is that liquid that
liquid is the body's response
to burns you know like it's it was just
blister juice
and i was just burned so [ __ ] badly
that i had
not like blisters but i had huge bags
of blister juice you ever wish they'd
bottle that stuff for you
i don't wish they bottled it but it is
it is fascinating that um
you know that's the body's response
that's why there is juice in the blister
it's your body's way of trying to cool
it down
you know like your body sends out you
know it sends out this liquid to just
try to
cool down the area and when i drank it
uh as as disgusting as it looked like
you know all yellow and and [ __ ] you
know crazy looking
um it honestly didn't taste like
anything man it didn't it did not taste
salty it didn't just it just tasted like
water
um bro it didn't look and that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was so gross i saved that for like
the [ __ ] credits yeah well you know
yeah he takes the knife and punctures it
and then you
fill up really a whole shot glass of
it and i was like oh no
i mean i i ended up with skin grafts on
15
of my body and so all of that was like
blisters just
all over me and uh the big bags i think
just
i don't know yeah i was [ __ ] so you
you described the doctors being shocked
that you didn't come into the hospital
early do you think you would have died
if you didn't go in because it seemed
like
i don't know i don't know that i would
have died but
god i that that was the worst [ __ ]
pain i've ever experienced
and and and and the saving grace of that
is that
by far the question i've been asked the
most
over the years is what was the most
painful stunt
you know like what hurt the most and the
question like
up until that point that question was
just like
frustrating to me because because there
was no good answer
i would say i would be like first like
frustrated that i got asked the question
again
and then i would say well there are
different criteria
for pain you know there's the acuteness
of the pain
like say for example if you get tased
you know like electricity
very acute but it's it's quick
you know the most important criteria to
me is the duration
of the pain you know like pain that
lasts for like you know
a week or two weeks is uh you know way
more upsetting to me than
so there's all these different criteria
and then when i got the third degree
burns like that
it checked every [ __ ] box man because
the show was
because the [ __ ] like i mean even after
i had the skin graft surgery
for to get more weeks it was the [ __ ]
unbearable pain you know like on the the
level of acute pain
duration like i went on a whole like
tour of burning it
after that and i heard over and over
that people who have been
shot like with guns and you know
and or stabbed will all say that uh
that's
nothing compared to third degree burns
like universally
third-degree burns are known as the most
[ __ ] horrific pain
and so i have an answer to the question
now you can ask me what's what hurt the
most not be like
yeah man [ __ ] fire angels yeah power
angels for sure bro
you know it's funny because you seem so
happy before the prank went off you're
like fire angels let's do it
yeah would you would you not do it or
would you do it again
i mean dude that's the thing like if i
knew that was gonna happen
i would it would be a really tough
decision to [ __ ] to go through with
it you know thank god
time doesn't operate that way where you
can go back
because like
i mean i wouldn't trade it for nothing
you know let me
let let me show you right here the uh
the t-shirt
that i was wearing i'm gonna
[ __ ] break the fourth wall a little
bit
like i was [ __ ] wearing nice
yeah dude i mean that surprised prized
possession right there
yeah i remember when you stood up the
whole back of your ass was burned off
like a comic book
yeah another anecdote from from gnarly
is that when you were protesting sea
world you
climbed up on this crane and were
shooting off fireworks and the
city the response was so insane they
sent like swat
teams and like 20 officers and fire
department 80
firefighters why i mean what and then a
swap why would they send a swat
team it's a really good question yeah
well like that doesn't even make any
sense well it doesn't make any sense but
i mean i think that the explanation is
that because the crane was 150 feet up
in the air
that it was impossible to tell
uh who it was climbing up on that crane
or why they were climbing up on that
crane and the backpack
that i was wearing um you know which had
my inflatable
killer whale and you know other you know
my fireworks and stuff
maybe i was some kind of a terrorist i
don't know maybe i guess the times were
a little wild
yeah it follows that it would have made
some sense
to do a little bit of investigation
before deploying
so many uh first responders but
you know what what can i do i can't
second guess it uh
and and i deserved all the trouble i got
in for that i legitimately felt [ __ ]
awful
i know they sent you a bill so i was
just wondering how much was the bill
um i approached it
um as uh
my investment was in um the attorney you
know i think that
i uh i i got like the most
impressive attorney that i could get in
that situation
and the attorney ended up costing more
than the bill
right for the restitution right because
i think that
had it gone in front of uh like a
trial jury you know and the obvious
question that would
you know require an answer is the
very question that you just asked why
the [ __ ] did they need a swat team
what was the purpose in 80 firefighters
like why
like why the helicopter why why all this
like you know that was such an
overblown overkill response and i think
that it when it came down to uh you know
what what's called arbitration
where they actually figure out like what
should this [ __ ] have to pay
i think that the uh the overblown
response
would uh would really be under the
microscope and um
so i'll go ahead and tell you dude i
spent 20 grand on the lawyer and
and he got the restitution uh at 14
damn that's not bad it's not bad like
you can already
i gotta say you could you could really
argue
that that was [ __ ] totally worth it
man you know
amazing that's amazing work for 20 000
from that attorney too
yeah and given how much um
[ __ ] press there was you know like
you know it's not press that looking
back on it i'm particularly proud of you
know it was
[ __ ] idiotic even though when uh and
it was like
there were rounds of press there was
when it happened press all over the
world
then they uh they [ __ ] sentenced me
to 30 days
in jail and that was headline city
the fact like stevo sentenced to 30 days
in jail
for a [ __ ] shamu you know [ __ ]
protesting sea world
it was it was a little bit of a a
[ __ ] total score but
to anybody who really looked at at what
what it was
it was just so dumb doing it where i did
it it had
nothing to do with sea world you know
like it was
nowhere near sea world it was all the
first
first responders i was blowing up
fireworks in
in hollywood like during a drought like
uh you know with the hell it was an
[ __ ]
move and and i was on probation for uh
for three years i was on probation
um and i had to do all kinds of
community service
they they let me do community service at
animal shelters
and uh for this um humane society
program
where i went around uh underserved
neighborhoods
um signing people up for free spay and
neuter
for their pets so i i was in [ __ ]
heaven with my community service
that's great yeah it was it was killer
and uh you were sentenced to 30 days but
but what did you serve like five hours
how did that happen eight hours
eight hours yeah i was from when i from
dude they let me
film turning myself to i showed up at
the [ __ ]
and then dude thank god that i made my
gnarly special
multimedia because everything i talked
about throughout the special you
actually
see you know the footage of it had cut
in
and i think it worked so well but i do i
showed up at the
the [ __ ] the what do you call the
correctional
uh facility the twin towers jail
to turn myself in for my 30-day sentence
i
climb up on the [ __ ] correctional
facility [ __ ]
sign and do a backflip off of it like
just like yeah
here i am i go in there and i'm like
here i am i turn myself in
they let it they let us film the whole
[ __ ] thing like how we went how they
like like they let us film them
handcuffing me and
leading me into the [ __ ] jail which i
cannot [ __ ] believe
and um and then they they uh
basically took my picture and let me go
i mean it was eight hours
from when i showed up at the jail to
when i walked out of the jail
and the reason for that is uh two things
um overcrowding you know like they don't
even
want uh i mean i shouldn't say they
don't
want they they don't have room to
keep anybody who's a non-violent
offender basically they're gonna they're
just
and then on top of that they don't
there's no upside
for the jail uh in having a high profile
uh inmate there's no upside like
anything like bad
happens that like they view it all as
liability and downside so
so yes they let me out in [ __ ] eight
hours which to me was hilarious what was
the eight hours like
what did you do in those eight hours uh
i mean mostly it's just being processed
in you know like uh you're you're in a
holding cell
you know you're waiting for them to like
get your fingerprints and
uh you know at one point like uh
i was picking out a book i was gonna
read
you know like getting ready to settle in
yeah
they were and um i mean
i knew as well that i was going to be in
protective custody that's what it's
called when you're a high-profile inmate
you know they they don't want they don't
want [ __ ] to deal with any
[ __ ] of uh like you being attacked
or anything
and so like and from back in the day it
was my
my uh second experience in that same
uh sort of high profile jail situation
in the same facility because i when i
was arrested for uh
the other thing and i was facing eight
years in prison
uh i showed up in there and and and they
pulled me out of my cell i just got in
my bag tattoo
and they pulled me out of my cell to
take pictures of me they're giving me
like
boxes of cookies this is back in 2002.
they're like oh dude
uh you're you're all good here man
[ __ ] um
you know like uh we call this robert
downey jr unit
rather than because we call this the
robert downey junior block
you know and and uh and the cell you're
in right now
that's odb cell he's always in here you
know
and they're used to like treating the
the celebrities nicely
i guess so pretty much man uh they were
they were
they're they were really cool to me back
in 2002 and they were super cool to me
uh and whatever it was it was a december
of 2015.
what did you almost go to jail for eight
years for
oh man it was [ __ ] awful and uh you
know
this is in the gnarly special where i
talk about how i got arrested for
stapling my balls
to my leg but in fact
in fact uh there were two charges
one was felony obscenity because this
was
this this was in uh in in louisiana
and and in louisiana there's not
counties
like there are in the states there's
parishes and there's like sort of
religious overtones
and like you know like the new orleans
is this
wild mardi gras party out of control but
once you get outside of new orleans
louisiana's pretty [ __ ]
crazy in the way they operate and i had
a show outside of new orleans in
louisiana
in 2002 and
during this show a couple things
happened i stapled my ball sack to my
leg and
as i did this and this is with the the
old tour which i promoted by saying
i will be drunk and on drugs or your
money
yeah yeah or your money back and in
every show on stage i would get drunk
[ __ ] on stage pounding tequila out of
the bottle i would have
audience members [ __ ] chugging
bottles of tequila
it was a [ __ ] liability central
[ __ ] show and i was on drugs every time
and and as i was uh covered in blood
like every show i was covered in blood i
was barfing all over the stage
like uh because i would break a light
bulb over my head and slash my tongue so
i was bleeding
all over myself this was every night it
was
every [ __ ] night and i would staple
them staple my balls to my leg during
the show
like uh i'd be set on fire i'd [ __ ]
be
pissing into it i'd be sick pissing into
a cup and i'd be like who wants to drink
my piss and people would be like yeah
so i'd bring people on yeah people would
be jumping up and down
who wants to get kicked in the nuts dude
it was a [ __ ]
it was a [ __ ] up circus dude and uh at
one point
at the point that night in louisiana
when i was stapling my balls to my leg
i just happened to say under the
microphone i said this is not
art this is strictly to be offensive
i don't even know why i said that
because it's totally art you know
and uh and somebody in the crowd was
videotaping
right it wouldn't have been a big deal
like the stapling of the balls to my leg
while i was covered in blood
saying that i was just trying to be
offensive but at another point in the
show
that bottle of tequila that i mentioned
i had it sitting on the stage like
towards the front of the stage
and at one point somebody
kind of crawled up onto the stage and
grabbed the bottle now the bouncers
noticed this happening they were not
they [ __ ] zipped over
with lightning speed and [ __ ]
incredible efficiency
and [ __ ] got that bottle back from
this person i was impressed
by the bouncers response to this theft
of my tequila bottle
these bouncers as it would turn out were
for football players for the local
college team
which i think was a pretty successful
college team well in any
case these huge bouncers these huge
bouncers impressed me
so i just off the cuff impromptu
i said to the crowd i said to the crowd
these bouncers are [ __ ] badass
who wants to try to run across this
stage
past the bouncers oh god well we'll call
it british bulldog
and they're ready to [ __ ] somebody up
who wants to try it
you know and the bouncers were all into
it yeah they were down man they were
super down
and then and then and everybody wants to
do it
but this one kid was just jumping higher
than everybody else he was just
all excited and i just could see the
kids excitement so i said you
the kid was like you know very small
he was i think 19 years old he got and i
orchestrated the whole thing so the kid
lines up and i said i'm filming it i
said on your mark
go whatever the kid runs it was pretty
anti-climactic
the kid just ran right into the bouncers
and they grabbed him right
but as an afterthought sort of and
clearly on the own
the bouncer's own initiative two of them
together they lifted this kid up in the
air
and [ __ ] body slammed him on the
stage
and yeah and like they body slammed the
kid like largely onto his head
you know and he was the kid was knocked
out
whoa unconscious he was just twitching
on the stage
unconscious i think i think he was like
bleeding out of his ear
like and you know it was a [ __ ]
pretty bad scene man it was a pretty bad
scene
and like you know the whole purpose of
the clowns in the circus is for when
uh when somebody falls off the trapeze
or whatever the clowns are supposed to
run in and divert attention
you know that was the whole purpose of
clowns you know like
the show's got to go on the clowns come
in be like hey you know we're good yeah
we're all you know so i've got this like
built in
the show must go on and so dude the kids
are twitching on the stage and i say
under the microphone
or whatever the kids are being loaded
into an ambulance at that point and i go
that kid's on a stretcher being loaded
into an ambulance
is that what we came here to see
everybody's like yeah you know
it was just it was just not not good so
the the kid who uh the
the person who was videotaping this
performance was uh
you know felt like okay i've documented
something with this camera that's
probably
like and they gave it to the news then
when they gave it to the news
the news was like oh this isn't as much
of a news story as a crime and then the
the the new so the news passed the tape
on to
the uh the on to the the city attorney
and the city attorney was like oh well
[ __ ] this guy
and uh and said they charred and by the
time the charges
were filed i was back in los angeles
and um and so they said they
put me on the fugitive list right but
here's the thing that
the fugitive i landed at number one
on the fugitive list by a mile by a mile
dude because
the [ __ ] uh they tried
they set my bail for the charge of
principal to second degree
battery you know it was a felony for for
orchestrating the thing where the kid
got slammed on his head
and they they set the bail for that at
200
dollars wow uh or or was it a hundred
and twenty thousand or
i uh one point one t 120 thousand
dollars i think it was or 1.2
yeah i don't know something like that
but they
also charged me with felony obscenity
for stapling my balls to my legs to the
parish and they're like you know
that was that felony a felony obscenity
i've never heard of such a charge
you're well right i mean there are there
there have been notable charges um
jim morrison was charged with felony
obscenity
in florida i think for showing his
wiener on stage
uh lenny bruce was charged with felony
obscenity
two live crew was famously charged with
felony obscenities so that charge
that charge added me to the list of
american heroes fantastic
yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh right and and
and they set my bail for the obscenity
charge at a full
one million dollars so i i landed on the
felony fugitive list with like 1.2
million 1.12 million i'm not sure which
dollar bail and that's the highest bill
i was number one on the list they
scooped me up and took me to the la
uh correctional facility and i want to
mention too
that that's like uh uh a little
[ __ ] morsel of this juicy ass book
that i wrote
right and i've got my book not only is
it
just a crazy book but it's a really
[ __ ] great book
as evidenced by the five-star rating
that it's maintained on amazon right
i love just this book is is so beautiful
and [ __ ] up and crazy and if you buy
it from my website stevo.com
every copy is personally autographed
and i loved i loved i like getting my
book out there i'd love to get my book
out there and
my new gnarly special you fulfill them
directly
how is it you're able to sign each one i
buy the books with an author discount
uh they get they get they get shipped to
my house sort of like if i was a store
like the same thing as if i was uh you
know a book
bookstore and they shipped the books to
my house
and when i say i personally i don't
personalize them they shipped in my
house and i autograph every
i sign every copy i sign every i
yeah i sign i do i spend a lot of time
signing and it ends radford
you know i sign every copy and then i
and then
my dude brings the books to the ups and
ships them to our fulfillment house
so what is the name of the book stevo
professional idiot a memoir
wow beautiful and that's on amazon i'm
going to buy that right now i'm going to
buy it right after that
yeah i wouldn't buy it on amazon i'd buy
it from stevo.com so you could have it
autographed you know you want to you
want to have the autographed copy but
for you my brother i'll [ __ ]
make one out next time i see it dude
i'll [ __ ] i'll give you i would love
that i'll give you
a special one so here's what i'm going
to encourage everybody listening to do
go to stevo.com buy gnarly for ten
dollars
it's gonna be an absolutely mind-blowing
hour special
and then when you're done zach can can
can zach chime in again
and just uh do you have an endorsement
for gnarly
my jaw was dropped and i've seen a lot
of crazy [ __ ] in my 22 years of life
that is by far the craziest [ __ ] i've
ever seen in my life
is that zach has been raving about the
show uh uh behind the scenes he has been
yeah i appreciate that so much man you
know it sucks that we that we waited for
so long
for my triumphant return to the h3
podcast
but you know but waiting that long i
really think uh
i think that we made another hit dude
yeah i think we made another hit
i can't i mean it's always a pleasure to
listen i mean you're you're full of so
many
uh incredible stories and uh such a
great guy i love having you on here
gnarly when you're done watching gnarly
buy the book
get it signed stevo.com is your one-stop
shop for steeple related paraphernalia
yeah dude the book you can actually use
paypal it's super easy to check out
but dude the gnarly special is so [ __ ]
up and
full of [ __ ] dick and grievous bodily
harm and [ __ ]
graphic drug abuse and just criminal
[ __ ] that if uh if
i put it out with paypal like it
wouldn't last 24 hours
it'd be shut down as pornography like
porn sites
yeah porn sites you can never use paypal
you know and
uh and it was it was only before we
before we went live with it so one of us
had this thought i wonder if that gets
if if uh if paypal shuts it down then
they shut down the whole online
operation you know we then we can't sell
anything
so we were like oh [ __ ] let's let's ask
about this and we did a little poking
around
and it turns and turns out that you have
we had to have
uh special bank approval with a special
account at a bank which has uh
quote an appetite for high risk credit
card
transactions which is what they call it
yeah what's
wrong with that appetite um i want to
say it's in
canada somewhere um but uh
but yeah basically any ban any uh
like porn you know like a webcam girls
like more sketchy kind of cbd you know
like uh sort of dark web [ __ ] and that
um is my is my explanation for why you
you
act have to do the it's just [ __ ]
scheduled
for that how do you pay for the thing
because i had dan buy it for me
yeah you gotta you gotta put in the it's
not that weird you just have to actually
plug in the credit card
and this is my this this is my
explanation my apology for not having a
quicker
easier checkout is that that the quicker
easier you know paypal amazon pay that
type of thing
would be more it would be more
convenient but those people don't like
uh
porn arguably bestiality when uh
that rock hard [ __ ] elk is bloody
[ __ ]
so was there actually was did he
penetrate you
no i i i didn't have a hole in the the
the costume i was wearing but there's a
scene where an
elk uh is fully torched and humped it
looks like he was [ __ ] you dude
yeah that was like really interesting
yeah because i was like i'm not sure
that you could legally
show you're right being penetrated by an
animal
but you did it um
many uh paypal would have called that
problematic yeah yeah that was
that was the first that was the first
thing and the only thing that would that
really entered the conversation as hey
this
gotta go and i said i said [ __ ] no
keep looking for [ __ ] banks we're
gonna fight we're gonna
we're gonna find the [ __ ] bank that's
okay with that [ __ ] rock hard elk
butt [ __ ] me
[Music]
i love the idea of someone at the bank
being like watching the whole special
and then being like
we can do this
yeah and then wait until the follow-up
you know is ready everybody go to the
same bank and be like okay so now
i'm actually [ __ ] now i'm at now it's
me that's hard
and i'm [ __ ] coming everywhere and i
gotta do it
but i think i think we're already in bed
with the right partner so
yeah exactly i i i think you are i think
you found your partner for life there
congratulations i'm so happy to see you
doing well you've got your podcast
you've got
all your specials and everything and you
know all your charity work and
everything it's just so nice to see and
and
thank you man thank you so much i'm
super happy
did likewise man i cannot tell you i i
have told you
but i can't really like
the the frequency with which i've heard
about
dude i heard you on the h3 podcast like
the uh
the frequency with dude i saw that [ __ ]
you in h3 it's great man what are you
gonna do together what's ethan really
like
you know like you know i i do i hear it
a lot
and uh you know i'm just stoked that i'm
stoked that the world is
the way it is that you know people like
us can kind of take the power of the
media into our own hands you know like
when i do certain podcasts and i think i
probably did this the last time
i was on with you i said hey like
because with podcasting you know like
retention
is a thing you know a lot of people
don't stick around to the very end you
know like we have the audience fall off
but it's the hardcore [ __ ]
like dedicated fans who stick around to
the very end i always address them
at the end of every episode of my
podcast wild ride with stevo
and i like to say thank you
for sticking around to the very end of
this podcast you guys are the ones
that really matter the most and i always
ask that my
uh the my i call them the street team i
say please take a screenshot
of this podcast and and post it
with tags for me and my guests to let my
guests know that they
that you enjoyed it you know and to kind
of
they made it all the way through and
that uh and to help me get the word
out and then build up this podcast and
that's why i call those people the
street team
and so for the h3 street team
um you know i i want to ask you guys who
made it all the way through
to shoot me a tweet let me know that
that you made it all right there
let's do something they can send which
is like do like uh
yeah are you not bad we're going to be
putting it out with proper videos so
really yeah oh yeah yeah that one
okay so so if you guys watch all the way
through to the end
send this image to stevo
people
there you go the real ones know only the
real ones now
yeah dude yeah it's something we should
start up here man the h3
streaks i like it a lot dude yes you
know you want
dude i don't know when this goes out but
as we recorded this
like [ __ ] fresh live on my uh podcast
channel i got mike
tyson today oh i love mike
he's such a [ __ ] guy that's that
should be really fun
it's a really fun one man i've been so
fortunate with my guests dude shaquille
o'neal
mike yeah your guest how the [ __ ] did
that happen
it's crazy uh yeah well i look forward
to it
so it's yours man your guest place is
epic
well starting with you
i don't know that i was uh that early on
but uh but yeah man it's a real pleasure
to reconnect dude
yeah and um yeah i want you to know that
the
cameras aside i just really appreciate
you man
we've made some of our my favorite
content together i mean
i we were talking on the phone you know
i don't think there's any other youtube
video where they've uh successfully
cut somebody's nuts off and the video is
still on youtube so
we hold that distinction together
demonetized
but still there it's still there that's
what matters
yeah still there yeah dude my youtube
channel is not big on monetization oh
yeah
that's still there right it's still
there dude that's right
have you got your uh diamond plaque yet
how far
no the thing is we pivoted we don't
really post on the main channel anymore
so
right so no we're
we're not on the diamond path yeah i'm
still fighting the fight man i'm on both
channels but not
but more regular with the podcast yeah
in any case i think we've we've
uh what do you call it uh
we've digressed into personal
conversation we should leave
leave the street team to their business
their hard work of promoting our shows
yes and uh and they've got they've got a
gnarly comedy special to watch
and a bug to read yeah you guys should
click off and get on that i agree
yeah all right take care man appreciate
you buddy